il nous a été refusé d'avoir accès aux
documents suivants la demande faite non
pas par vous même
mais comme vous l'avez dit dans un
second temps par monsieur le directeur
de cabinet de bord d'armes
il est étrange qu'on nous ait refusé de
la connaissance de ce document est ce
que vous avez ce document alors je pense
qu'il n'existe pas de documents vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que le directeur
de cabinet du président de la république
est en lien avec tous les préfets il a
dû décrocher son téléphone et demande à
michel delpech de voir si dans les
règles il était possible de ma tribu une
autorisation
je me considérais que ce port d'armes
qui a été refusé deux fois pour des
raisons administratives par le ministère
de l'intérieur a été attribué par
monsieur yann drouet que nous allons
recevoir sur un coup de téléphone alors
pas une demande écrite alors je pense
que c'est pas la procédure en l'espèce
c'est que dans un premier temps il ya
une personne qui appelle une autre
personne et qui demande voilà de quelle
situation on est confronté ce que vous
pouvez regarder si c'est possible si ça
rentre dans les clous des ans patrick
strzoda est quelqu'un d'assez prudent et
de trait dans les règles et c'est
quelqu'un de très droit
c'est quelqu'un de très droit il n'a
exercé aucune pression ni téléphonique
n'est simplement il a appelé préfet de
police en lui disant voilà la situation
dans laquelle et alexandre qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire et le préfet de police
par la suite a saisi ses services son
cabinet dans un premier temps donc son
chef de cabinet ian drew et et yann
drouet a saisi la direction de la police
générale qui a écrit cet arrêté est donc
par avant d'écrire cet art était
d'ailleurs qui m'a demandé un certain
nombre de documents justificatifs
permettant de prouver un et d'ailleurs
ils sont mentionnés il me semble dans
l'arrêté que j'avais les capacités à
porter une arme que je n'étais pas
soumis à quelconque
problèmes d'ordre psychologique mais
j'ai fourni un certain nombre de
documents
mais les échanges écrits se font entre
l'intéressé et les services pas entre le
préfet de police et son direct et le
directeur de cabinet du président la
république il s'appelle il va plier
enfin je pense qu'il n'a pas le temps
déjà deux pour écrire un courrier il ya
une saisie administrative officiel entre
l'intéressé et le service le service en
l'occurrence sa direction la police
générale son quatrième bureau de mémoire
reid en sueur